>> Jeanine: PRESIDENT BIDEN
CAUGHT ON A HOT MIC TRYING TO
ACT LIKE A TOUGH GUY AND USING
SOME SALTY LANGUAGE.
>> NO ONE [BLEEP] WITH --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jeanine: BIDEN BRAGGING
THAT NO ONE MESSES WITH HIM.
BUT APPARENTLY NO ONE HAS TOLD
HIM THAT THE WHOLE WORLD IS.
THE SAUDIS AND OPEC EMBARRASSING
THE PRESIDENT BY CUTTING OIL
PRODUCTION AFTER HE BEGGED THEM
REPEATEDLY TO PRODUCE MORE.
AND WITH GAS PRICES ALREADY
SURGING, BIDEN MIGHT BE FORCED
TO SUCK UP TO THE SOCIALIST IN
VENEZUELA FOR OIL.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
OPEC?
>> DISAPPOINTMENT.
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT
ALTERNATIVES WE MAY HAVE.
>> IS VENEZUELA?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF
ALTERNATIVES.
>> Jeanine: HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
PERFECTLY SUMMING UP BIDEN'S WAR
ON AMERICAN ENERGY.
>> THINK OF WHAT HE DID ON THE
VERY FIRST DAY, ENDING AMERICAN
PIPELINE, STOPPING LEASES, HE
HAS MADE US DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA,
SAUDI ARABIA, AND NOW VENEZUELA.
HE HATES AMERICAN OIL FIELD
WORKERS SO MUCH THAT HE WILL
NEVER RETURN TO US.
>> Jeanine: YOU KNOW, THE
AMAZING PART OF ALL OF THIS IS
THERE IS THE ABILITY FOR
AMERICA, JESSE, TO PUMP OUR OWN
OIL, AND YET THE PRESIDENT
PREFERS TO SEEK IT FROM
SOCIALISTS, GO ON BENDED KNEE TO
THE SAUDIS AND OPEC.
WHY?
>> Jesse: BECAUSE IF YOU
LISTEN TO HIS ANSWER, IT IS
ALWAYS THE SAME.
WE HAVEN'T MADE UP OUR MIND YET.
THAT IS BECAUSE HE IS NOT THE
ONE MAKING THE DECISION.
SOMEONE ELSE IS TELLING BIDEN
WHAT HIS MIND WILL TELL HIM TO
MAKE UP BECAUSE HE DOESN'T -- HE
IS A STOOGE, HE IS A PUPPET.
WE ARE NOT GETTING ANY OIL FROM
VENEZUELA.
THAT ECONOMY IS COLLAPSING, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRUMBLING.
THAT IS A LONG-TERM PLAY.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE STAIRS OF
AIR FORCE ONE F WITH BIDEN, AND
THE BIKE, JUST TO BE ACCURATE
THERE.
HERE MIGHT HAVE THE GUY -- I
KNOW, GREG, I KNOW WE ALL KNOW
PEOPLE LIKE THIS -- THEY ARE
OVERCOMPENSATING, RIGHT?
THEY ARE TALKING TOUGH BECAUSE
DEEP DOWN THERE IS REALLY NOT A
LOT THERE.
I CAN DO MORE PUSH-UPS THAN YOU.
I GRADUATED WITH HONORS.
NO, YOU DIDN'T.
YOU BASICALLY WERE LAST IN YOUR
CLASS.
HE FEELS THAT WAY BECAUSE HE
FEELS LIKE HE IS UNTOUCHABLE
BECAUSE HE HAS THE CIA AND THE
FBI AND THE BIG MEDIA BEHIND
HIM.
EVEN SOMETIMES MADE MEN GET
TAKEN OUT, AND I THINK THAT IS
WHAT IS STARTING TO HAPPEN.
IF YOU SEE HIGH GAS PRICES,
STOCK MARKET CORRECTION, OPEN
BORDERS, CRIME WAVE, INFLATION,
THIS GUY IS TEETERING ON THE
BRINK EPIC COLLAPSE AND I THINK
EVERYONE SEES THE WRITING ON THE
WALL.
>> Jeanine: OKAY, THE WRITING
ON THE WALL AS WE EITHER BEG
VENEZUELA, GREG, OR -- THIS IS
NOT AN OPTION ON THE TABLE.
TO DEVELOP OUR OWN RESOURCES.
WHY IS AMERICA NOT GIVEN THE
OPTION TO BE INDEPENDENT?
WHY DOES HE HATE THIS COUNTRY SO
MUCH?
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK HE
HATES THIS COUNTRY SO MUCH.
>> Jeanine: WELL, WHY --
>> Greg: REASONS BEYOND HIM
HATING THE COUNTRY.
FIRST, I AM NOT A MIND READER,
JUDGE.
I WOULD BE MORE INTERESTED IN
ADDRESSING THE TOPIC, WHICH IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ONE OF THE
DAY, HIS SWEARING.
NOW, I WAS DISGUSTED BY IT.
I WAS DEEPLY OFFENDED BY THE
SWEARING.
IT IS HARD FOR ME SITTING NEXT
TO DANA BECAUSE SHE HAS A MOUTH
LIKE A DRUNK LONGSHOREMAN, SO I
AM PRETTY NUMB TO IT, BUT JUST
HEARING HIM SAY THAT WORD, IT
TRIGGERED ME BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT IT DID?
IT MADE ME MISS TRUMP.
BECAUSE HE SWORE ALL THE TIME!
WHO CARES ABOUT THE SWEARING?
MY IMPRESSION IS THAT JOE
INTERPRETS HIS SURROUNDINGS FAR
DIFFERENTLY THAN THE MANAGED
REALITY AROUND HIM, RIGHT?
HE IS LIKE PLAYING VIRTUAL
REALITY PRESIDENT, BUT HE
DOESN'T EVEN NEED HAD SAID.
THINK ABOUT IT.
I DON'T TAKE ANY PLEASURE IN
THIS DISASTER, THOUGH, BUT IT
AFFECTS EVERY WAY TRUMP'S TWEETS
AND WORDS NEVER DID.
THERE ARE ACTUAL PHYSICAL
CONSEQUENCES TO THIS ENERGY
NONPOLICY, TO THE CRIME, TO THE
INFLATION, TO THE WOKE POLICIES,
AND YOU STILL, LIKE YESTERDAY,
YOU HAD THE MEDIA, DEMOCRATS
FRETTING THAT TRUMP MIGHT RETURN
TO TWITTER BECAUSE OF ELON MUSK.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT, WHAT IT MIGHT DO TO THEIR
FRAGILE PSYCHE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WERE DOING ON
THE NETWORKS YESTERDAY.
>> Jeanine: DANA, IF YOU WERE
PRESIDENT  --
>> Dana: OH.
>> Jeanine: WHAT WOULD YOU DO
ABOUT THE LACK OF OIL IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> Dana: THAT'S PRETTY EASY, I
WOULD CALL UP THE BIG OIL PEOPLE
AND SAY WHAT YOU GOT, WHAT DO
YOU NEED, LET'S GO FOR IT.
I WOULD DO OPERATION WORK SPEED
ON OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE IT HERE, WE
SHOULD DO IT.
THERE IS A VERY EXCITING
TRANSITION AHEAD -- THERE IS A
LOT OF INNOVATION FOR FUSION OR
DIFFERENT WAYS TO POWER OUR
ECONOMY.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THERE
EVENTUALLY.
TO GET THERE, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
FOSSIL FUELS, AND UNTIL THAT
POINT, I WOULD TRY -- IF I WERE
A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT, I WOULD
SAY I HEAR YOU ON CLIMATE
CHANGE, I AM WITH YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE, HERE'S WHAT
I'M DOING TO GET US TO A POINT
WHERE WE HAVE ZERO EMISSIONS
ENERGY, BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE
ARE GOING TO NEED THESE FOSSIL
FUEL COMPANIES TO DO WHAT THEY
ARE BEST AT DOING FEAR OF I WILL
TELL YOU ONE THING THEY'RE NOT
GOOD AT DOING, AND THAT IS
DEFENDING THEMSELVES.
I AM JUST SHOCKED, THEY SIT
THERE AND ALLOW US TO DEFEND
THEM.
WHERE ARE THEY?
WHERE ALL OF THE BIG CEOs?
THEY ARE HIDING.
I THINK IT IS BAD, I THINK IT IS
BAD FOR THE ECONOMY, IT IS BAD,
THEY COULD WRITE A LETTER AND DO
A STATEMENT, BUT THERE IS NOBODY
OUT THERE ACTUALLY DRIVING THE
MESSAGE EXCEPT FOR THEIR
ASSOCIATION IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
WHICH IS FINE AND GOOD, BUT WHY
ARE YOU GUYS OUT THERE DEFENDING
YOUR ENERGY WORKERS?
DON'T JUST LEAVE IT TO US, YOU
GUYS SHOULD GET OUT THERE AND DO
IT, TOO P OF THE LAST THING ON
THE F-BOMB FROM BIDEN, WHY ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT YOURSELF IN
THE MIDDLE OF A DISASTER ZONE?
>> Greg: THAT'S FUNNY.
"THE FIVE" NOBODY AT HER Fs
WITH ME?
WE ARE HERE TO TALK ABOUT --
>> Jesse: LIKE WHEN KAMALA WAS
AT THE DMZ, HAVE YOU SEEN THE
HUBBLE TELESCOPE?
>> Greg: THEIR OWN REALITY.
>> Jeanine: SO WHAT WILL BE
DUE?
>> Harold: THIS IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE, THINK ABOUT
REDUCING OUR DEPENDENCE ON
OVERSEAS SUPPLIERS, WHETHER IT
IS SOME PHARMACEUTICAL, ENERGY
IS THE KEY, WE SPENT A MOST
$100 BILLION IN UKRAINE, I THINK
RIGHTLY SO, HELPING THE
UKRAINIANS DEFEND AGAINST PUTIN
FOR A SINGLE REASON, ENERGY,
PUTIN HAS ENERGY.
DANA RIGHTLY SAID, DEMOCRATS
WANT TO TRANSITION TO MORE
EFFICIENT WAYS FOR ENERGY TO BE
USED, BE IT SOLAR, YOU CAN'T
RIDE AN AIRPLANE, FARM, PRODUCE
CONCRETE, YOU CAN DO BASIC
MANUFACTURING WITHOUT FOSSIL
FUELS.
WE ARE KIDDING OURSELVES IF WE
DON'T MAKE THE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS, AND WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY AND ABILITY TO DO SO.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN,
RHETORICALLY READY TO GET THERE,
GET THERE SOONER.
SOME OF THE RIVAL NETWORKS THIS
MORNING TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE,
WE WOULD BE SAYING EXACTLY WHAT
IS BEING SET ON THIS SHOW, LET'S
LET'S CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
GREEN ENERGY PLATFORMS, LET'S
INVEST IN WAYS TO MAKE SOLAR
PANELS, BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
BE DEPENDENT ON CHINA FOR SOLAR
PANELS, FIVE YEARS FROM NOW.
TAKES ENERGY TO DO THIS, AS
WELL.
IT IS NOT ANY EMBARRASSMENT AT
ALL FOR US TO SAY WE NEED TO DO
THIS.
LET'S GET TO IT SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER.
>> Jeanine: IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Harold: ONLY IN THE
UNITED STATES FEARED
>> Jeanine: OF NEXT, AS CRIME
EXPLODES AND LIBERAL CITIES, THE